[Musique]
bravo messieurs bravo on est tous très
fiers de vous ils sont vraiment d'aquin
grand plaisir que j'accueille
aujourd'hui au sein de notre entreprise
une ergonome hautement qualifiés je
m'appelle alix malherbe et je veux
passer quelques temps parmi vous devez
vous demander séquelles ergonomie ça
fait mal alix je vous présente vital
c'est notre chef d'ekin chanter
aujourd'hui nous commençons avec une
analyse excuse puisque vous pourrez vous
allonger sur la table faute de quoi les
gars f tueur court de trésorerie même
pour acheter du fils alors j'ai pas le
choix
c'est quoi cette histoire d'études à
l'usiné du patron ça n'inquiète pas
cautionner malheur c'est mon sa mère
alice barres étiquettes appelant vrai tu
veux être à larissa je mangeais mon
thermale dominant qu'est ce que tu
racontes
[Musique]
tulasne décrocher un job en or au canada
alors tu sors pas avec l'équipe comme ça
c'est tout petit coin ça ne saurait
tarder
c'est le seul domaine contre huit
cerveaux de petite conne
je comprends pas ce que tu fous j'ai
envie de prendre l'air
[Musique]